en france la droite est agité par une
nouvelle polémique à propos du pacs le
week-end dernier certains jeunes
militants se sont en effet élevées
contre les positions défendues par
christine boutin en demandant une
modernisation le discours semble avoir
été entendu au rpr à l'udf en revanche
la députée se dit soutenu par les
leaders du parti eric thybaud alexandre
dupont christine boutin ne renonce pas
ses larmes ont séché depuis le débat sur
le pacs à l'assemblée nationale et
justement elle en a fait un livre les
larmes de la république
certes elle se dit peiné par les propos
tenus contre elle ce week-end
mais elle affirme aussitôt que la
position de l'udf contre le pacte civil
de solidarité n'a pas changé qui est
certain c'est qu'à la fois françois
bayrou fait de ce blazy et anne marie
idrac ont tenu à me téléphoner hier pour
me manifester leur soutien et me dire
combien ma position était celle du
groupe et qu'il n'y avait pas de tes
propos homophobes
christine boutin accuse à mots couverts
les chefs de l'udf de tenir un double
langage suivant les circonstances et
pour bien enfoncer le clou elle brandit
les mots de soutien de ses collègues
comme autant de bons points aux airs
faire l'affairé plus simple
nicolas sarkozy a pu facilement adoucir
son discours contre le pacs car personne
n'avait flux de propos outranciers alors
roselyne bachelot que tu aujourd'hui
affirmé que ses collègues la rejoigne
petit à petit tiers des électeurs de
moins de 35 ans était favorable au pacte
civil de solidarité et j'avais dit que
finalement la droite ne remercierai dans
quelques années d'avoir pris la position
que j'avais adopté lors du débat sur le
pacte civil de solidarité
je pensais qu'il nous fallait quelques
années je pensais pas qu'il faudrait
simplement quelques semaines pour en
arriver là
toutefois le rpr comme l'udf à quelques
exceptions près votre rencontre le pacs
en dernière lecture à l'assemblée
nationale
bref derrière l'apparence
secours la droite cherche encore le
chemin de la rénovation